our dreamers uh they make us so proud
they helped in so many ways as the
distinguished here
has indicated so for us this is a day
of not only passing legislation but a
cause
for celebration with that i'm very
pleased to yield to the person
as i said this is her day for many
reasons congress
madam chair the chair of the homeland
security subcommittee of appropriations
where she has fought this fight for a
long time congresswoman
good morning everyone i thank speaker
pelosi for making the dream and promise
act
one of the top 10 democratic priorities
for this congress
i also thank my co-authors congresswoman
nida velazquez
and yvette clark as well as though law
friend
for her invaluable guidance and
leadership as chair of the judiciary
subcommittee
on immigration
after 20 years of fighting to protect
dreamers
and as co-author of the original dream
act i am truly thrilled
that today the house will take a major
step
in ending the veil of fear and
uncertainty
that has plagued the lives of our
dreamers for far
too long as our nation has battled the
culvert 19 pandemic
202 500
daca recipients have risked their lives
as essential workers
they have packaged and stocked our food
taught our children
and worked as cherry said as doctors
nurses and caregivers to protect our
health and safety
well each dreamer has a unique story
they all exemplify american values
and a deep love for the only nation
they call home i thank my colleagues
for their support and for being here
today
to
thanks so much this is in fact a great
day you know one of the things
that we have been fortunate for during
this
horrible pandemic is that our food
supply was never disrupted we could
always go
to the supermarket and find food now
let's thanks to the farmers of america
but also the farm workers of america
most of whom are undocumented and most
of whom have been here more than 10
years
they live in a period of uncertainty
and we decided we should do something
about it who is we
united farm workers union and the
growers
talked to each other for over a year to
try and
see if we could come up with a path
forward
republicans and i want to call out
specifically congressman
dan newhouse and mike simpson as well as
many others
and myself and jimmy panetta and jimmy
costanza
and many others work together to come up
with a compromise that will allow
farm workers to gain legal status and
also to regularize the existing
h2a program so that farmworkers in the
future
can come over in a legal and orderly
manner
this bill is a compromise of into
bipartisan compromise
it's a compromise between farmers
and farm workers it's something i hope
that will pass a bipartisan support
if it does america will be stronger
than it is today i yield now to
a wonderful person who's worked so hard
on the
tps matter and that is the chairwoman of
velasquez good morning everyone thank
you
uh cheerleading and um
i want to thank chairman ruth
speaker for osce leader hoyer
and all the other amazing advocates for
humane
immigration reform and let me just
remind
everyone immigration
and immigrants make america
america and to all the activists
the grassroots organization who stood up
and stood firm to demand a more
just immigration system this bill are
made possible
by you as a co-author of the dream and
promise act along with representative
royga
allard and yvette clark i am proud that
this bill
will shield qualifying recipients of cps
tps ded and daca from deportation
and create a more comprehensive pathway
to citizenship these are our co-workers
friends families and hard-working
law-abiding members of our community
this deal is the morally right thing to
do
is the fiscally responsible move and
most of all
it is the american way forward thank you
and this is one thing
[Music]
thank you very much i want to thank
chairman
ruiz for bringing us together today
lucille roybal lillard and zoe lofgren
and all the others assembled here for
sponsoring the two bills we're
considering this afternoon
and of course our distinguished leaders
speaker pelosi and majority leader hoyer
for bringing these important bills to
the floor
after closing the book on four years of
disastrous cruel and inhumane
immigration policies today we begin a
new chapter
it is one based on compassion on reason
and the fundamental values we hold dear
as americans
all of the individuals who would gain
protection under the bills we're
considering today
dreamers tps and ded recipients and farm
workers
are vital members of our communities as
though said without the immigrant farm
workers
the undocumented immigrant farm workers
we couldn't grow our crops and feed our
people
they are our neighbors our friends our
classmates our service members and our
essential workers
they are driving forces in our economy
and in our culture
the two bills we will pass today
recognize that america is stronger
when we welcome people to our shores
later this afternoon the house has sent
a clear message
that we believe in a just rational and
humane immigration system
i hope that our senate colleagues will
hear us on the other side of the capitol
and will take similar actions i'm proud
to stand with my colleagues here today
and i look forward to sending both of
these important bills to the president's
desk
let me uh thank chairman ruiz speaker
pelosi
my colleagues congressman lucille roybal
allard
congresswoman nydia velasquez of course
chairwoman law friend and chairman jerry
nadler
and all of my colleagues in the chc i'm
conference committee betsy clark
i proudly represent new york's ninth
congressional district
central and south brooklyn as the
daughter of jamaican immigrants
i understand the need the need for the
dream
and promise act and a 21st century
immigration system
worthy of our great nation
let me be clear our current immigration
system
is broken and to coin a phrase
of a another very distinguished
jamaican-american the notorious b.i.g
if you don't know now you know
imagine being bought to the united
states of america
you're on a road trip with the family
you're a child
you're observing your surroundings
you come to a new place you settle
you grow up with other children you
dream he was fired you reach your goals
you're educated you're engaged
only to find out you're undocumented
only to find out that the work that you
have done to help build this country
has not been given the same value as if
you were born
in this nation today
we are saying let us continue to build
on the american dream
let us pass the dream and promise act we
have an
obligation to bring forth
the type of support undergirding that
needs to happen for those who have been
a lifeline
to so many families across this nation
not only
during this pandemic before it and will
continue to do so
as proud americans as we passed the
dream of promising
with that i think it was a minute i
yield back
thank you good morning everyone thank
you representative clark chairman ruiz
and speaker pelosi for this opportunity
to speak in support
of the american dream and promise act i
am proudly a member of both the
congressional black caucus
and the congressional asia pacific
islander caucus here in u.s congress
for the 1.5 million asian dreamers and
2.1 million african immigrants
the american dream and promise act isn't
just any piece of legislation
it is a pathway to citizenship that will
determine
their future in this country in this
place that they call home
in this place for millions of people who
have known no other home but the united
states
and i want to talk a bit about the
recipients who are going to come from
korea
and from the continent of africa koreans
are one of the first groups to sign up
for daca when it was announced by
president obama
and immigrants from africa from nigeria
ethiopia
ghana encountered to name a few are now
among the fastest
growing group of immigrants across the
united states creating a viable pathway
to citizenship
and acceptance is something that all
undocumented immigrants
grapple with i want to thank the
congressional hispanic caucus for
leading the way on this issue
and i want to encourage everyone to
support
these bills and i say this because we
talk about bipartisanship here in
congress
but these bills are wildly popular with
the american public
america wants these things to happen
we've been talking about this for too
long
and now is the time to act it's the
morally right thing to do
it's the courageous thing to do that's
good for the economy
and it epitomizes what it means to be
american i know
you to representative thank you
thank you madam speaker and uh
chairman louise uh sure woman uh
royal holler chair woman uh solo after
for your leadership and your efforts in
bringing us together
to uh this important day and it is an
important day it's a good day
for uh reform in our immigration system
in this country
as was noted we have a broken
immigration system and it's been that
way for decades
and it's time we get about the work of
fixing it
the legislation that we will put on
today will cover
almost half or maybe as much as of the
undocumented people that we have in our
country today
and give them legal status
let me start where i think i come from
food is a national security issue it's
not often looked at that way
we take it for granted but certainly in
the last 12 months with this pandemic
with closure of schools and restaurants
and our complicated complex food supply
chain turned upside down
i think more americans are beginning to
understand
how critical it is for the five percent
of the population the nation's
population
that puts food on america's dinner table
every night
i know because i'm a third generation
farmer
it's a partnership it always has been a
partnership between farm workers
farmers dairy men and women and
it's that partnership that has been part
of the great success of america
that allows us not only to feed all of
our people but to also produce
enough food for other parts of the world
where they are in need
let me tell you something the coalition
that came together was a result of the
hard work of a lot of folks here
the united farm workers who many of us
worked with for years
the grower organizations and much of
organized labor
understanding that farm workers
the compasinos who
make up such a wonderful part of our
country in the samuel king valley that i
represent
are some of the hardest working
individuals i have ever met
yes i know these cappucinos from the
time i was a young man
on my family's farm until an adult i
work side by side with them
i know what hard work is all about
and they are trying to do their best to
raise their families
and to have a better opportunity and a
brighter future for themselves and their
and for our country yet it is simply
wrong for them to live
and work under the shadow of uncertainty
and fear
of being deported that's what it is
it's that fear that they live with from
day to day
maria who i spoke with a few months ago
lived in parliament she picks
uh and works in an orange packing shed
as risen in the ranks there but she left
a few months ago from this good paying
job she purchased a home she had her
family because some of her family was
documented so was not
and therefore the word was out that the
immigration service was looking at
deporting and making a raid at this
packing champion
that's real that's fear so let me close
by saying that when we talk about some
of the hardest working men and women
and their young children who put food on
america's dinner table every night
today we are going to give them hope
the hope that they have that i see in
their eyes when i go to my district
every week
a hope for a normal life free from the
dread of family separation
family separation and deportation that
hangs over their head
every day when they leave to go to work
hope for a chance to change their
reality and reshape their story and live
the american green for ladies and
gentlemen
our nation is a land of immigrants past
and immigrants present i know
i'm a second generation immigrant my
grandparents came to this country
illiterate non-english speaking
as farm workers they melt cats
i have some skill sets that i still have
but the fact is is today we can make a
difference and i want to thank so much
so lucille and doctor
let me introduce one of my partners who
said
salute carvajal has historian he and i
represent some of the largest
agricultural regions
in california therefore in the country
jimmy panetta and so many others have
worked so hard in this effort
along with the new house congressman
salud
from the great central coast thank you
representative costa
let me start by thanking a few people
uh that really have brought us here
first i want to thank
dr reese for organizing today's event
but the two authors of these two
important bills
work extremely hard to get us here and i
want to recognize representative
laughter
representative allen for getting this
here
and let's face it nothing happens here
without
leadership not only from the individuals
i mentioned but
from our extraordinary speaker nancy
pelosi i want to thank them for getting
it
thank you very much i'm a
son of a farmworker many in summer
anxiety
toiled in the fields with my father i
know firsthand
the hard work of farm workers i also
happen to represent
a district where the number one industry
is agriculture
so making sure that our farm workers are
taken care of and that our
farmers uh have the tools and and
the assistance they need to prosper is
of the utmost importance to me
this is personal to me many of these
immigrants
via dreamers or farm workers come to
this country to live the american dream
come to ensure that their kids have a
better way of life
some of them even become members of
congress
so today is a good day for america
these bills are bipartisan we have
bipartisan members of congress that have
come together
and a diverse group of stakeholders
especially the farm workforce
modernization act
this is a bill that is historic when you
consider all of the groups that came
together to make it happen
today is an important day to not just
take all that our country and our
economy has been taking from immigrants
their essential work
to keep america working but recognizing
them
and giving them back that benefit
to live that american dream in this
country that they came here for
thank you very much
i want to close by giving my sincere
appreciation
adoration and respect to chair zoe
lofgren
and to chair lucille roybal allard
and to speaker pelosi and all the
members who spoke today members
representing uh
both capex and cbc you see that
the diversity not only that are up here
but all those that are affected by
this broken immigration system and
together we can get it fixed
thank you very much and that concludes
our press conference
[Music]
you